i went to law school and upon graduating  law school i was fortunate enough to  have two job offers one was to be a  district attorney and accelerate my  litigation career and make tons of money  being a dirty lawyer no offense and then  two  was to work in the internet  and to sell legal research online  so of course i went to uh my  favorite advisor my mom and i asked her  what should i do mom what should i do  and she said quote unquote dave you  should be a real lawyer because this  internet thing you know this internet  it's a fad  thank goodness for the first time in my  life for the first time in my life i  didn't listen to my mom and i learned a  valuable lesson though i learned the  lesson that just because someone loves  you  doesn't mean that they give you good  advice  just as if uh great philosophers  sometimes support some things that just  aren't true